hello and happy monday to ya i'm dave
rubin it's october 4th
this is the reuben report direct message
i don't know why i did a little irish
brogue there it just popped in my head
right before we started i never know
what i'm gonna say right at the top of
the show i went irish here we go i don't
know what are you gonna do
three stories for you and i'm in a good
mood i had a great weekend it's very
obvious to me that all of the bad stuff
is going to continue to get worse and
the craziness is going to continue to
come but the best that i can do is enjoy
my life spread the ideas that i care
about and continue to fight for the
things that i believe in and hopefully
have a few of you come on the ride for
me and and do the same in your lives
that's the best we can do so we're just
going to keep doing it uh so yes
everything's kind of getting worse we're
going to discuss all that kind of stuff
but like if you can kind of go about
your life and pill for some happiness in
the midst of it that's pretty damn good
uh we got four stories for you today
first we're going to do a little preview
of a interview that i did on friday i
was supposed to be on the local fox
channel here in los angeles to do a show
what's the name of the show called the
issues
the issue is
uh with a host by the name of alex
michelson i believe is his name and i
went there i drove there with my
producer michael
and it was going to be a live in-person
interview one-on-one with elix he was
going to ask me how i felt about
california and all the recall stuff and
that and then i was going to do
a one-on-one debate with famous i mean
legendary civil rights attorney gloria
allred well when we got to the building
which is about 20 minutes from where i
live when we got to the building they
demanded that they see our vaccine cards
or they would not let us in
and i just simply will not play that
game and my producer michael felt the
same way i think what you inject
yourself with or what medical decisions
you make for yourself are your business
and nobody else's
and i said i'm not going to do that
they said they would not let me in
that the policy had just started the day
before
and they were not let me in it was a
corporate thing so i ended up doing the
interview
from home
and you know what why don't we just show
the good people a little brief clip of
my interview with gloria allred so i i
don't really understand the connection
actually are you a good decent citizen
are you vaccinated
it's nobody's business whether i'm
vaccinated that's like me asking you the
last time you got laid i mean it's just
irrelevant
come on
pretty good
that's pretty good you know that's
pretty good uh the interview continued
and it sort of de-escalated from there
she sort of did
the usual sort of progressive sort of
overreach and not really saying anything
and just throwing out a bunch of numbers
that didn't really go anywhere we're
going to show one more clip in a little
bit when i get to this fouchy thing in
just a sec but i
tell you all of this to say that the
full debate is up right now it just went
up on youtube on our channel about an
hour ago so when you're done watching
this you can click over there to see the
whole thing and then the three stories
we got for you today uh this fouchy guy
who has consistently gotten absolutely
everything wrong and taken every which
position every position available on
simply everything for the last year and
a half but now he's saying that maybe we
can't get together for christmas
remember when old joe biden said we
could maybe get together for july for
july 4th remember when uh they told us
two weeks to flatten the curve it just
never ends with these people it's never
going to stop and as i said we just have
to figure out how to go about our lives
despite these lunatics trying to control
us at every possible level that's story
number one story number two uh
representative ayanna presley who is one
of the squad she's in this aoc ohana
omar rashida to leave this gang of
lunatics
she gave an absolutely ridiculous speech
about abortion and i've often said to
you guys how it's not um
sort of the the good arguments of the
pro-life people that i've argued
abortion with when i hear ben shapiro or
glenn back or dennis prager or others
take the pro-life position that has
shifted me on abortion it's that the
left has gone so crazy with abortion
that i just want nothing to do with that
as they go crazy with everything so
we're gonna play some video on that and
then the big story of the weekend was
that you know we all know about this 3.5
trillion
dollar bill that the democrats are
trying to push through congress and of
course they keep telling us 3.5 trillion
dollars is gonna actually cost zero
which we all know is a lie 3.5 trillion
equals 3.5 trillion zero equals zero a
burrito costs ten dollars it doesn't
cost zero dollars even if you steal ten
dollars from someone else uh well
kristen cinema who is one of the
senators the the what i would say are
the last squashy moderate democratic
senators from arizona uh her and joe
manchin have been the two democrats sort
of stopping this thing from being passed
all the republicans are against it and
now a gang of activists was chasing her
around and actually followed her into
the bathroom and then joe biden kind of
defended them today so that's kind of
where we're at in terms of political
discourse it's almost like when maxine
waters was telling people to get in
their face remember that last summer get
in their face show them that you're here
that maybe some people were going to
take it literally and now the president
of the united states is defending it
absolutely ludicrous anyway we're going
to get to all that but before we do i
want to talk to you about ladder you
know i want to talk for a minute about
things that have fundamentally changed
the way we live these things are the
disruptors things like smartphones
streaming services or dogs named clyde
who like to jump on you each time you
come home another disrupter i heard of
recently is a company called ladder who
basically took the life insurance
industry flipped it upside down and
shook out the inefficiencies before
ladder if you wanted to get life
insurance you had to drive across town
sit through a sales pitch fill out a ton
of paperwork and then wait six to eight
weeks to figure out if you'd been
approved you'd also receive a zillion
phone calls from agents trying to bundle
your life insurance with things like car
insurance now with ladder you can get
fast affordable life term term life
insurance without leaving home it's a
hundred percent digital when you apply
for three million dollars or less in
coverage no doctors no needles no
paperwork so if you're between the ages
of 20 and 60 need coverage you want to
team up with a company that's redeeming
life insurance choose ladder the process
is super quick and easy go to
ladderlife.com
reuben today to see if you're instantly
approved that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life
dot com slash reuben lottery life.com
reuben now back to me all right fouchy
let's uh talk about this fouchy guy i
think you all know my feelings on him
and i've been really thinking about it
and when we decided to do this story
this morning
i thought about it it's like
do i think anthony fauci dr anthony
fauci the highest paid person in the
federal government who clearly is
enjoying the spotlight on this thing and
spends most of his time just going to
fundraisers and being on television and
all that stuff do i think he's enjoying
locking people down do i think he's
enjoying
keeping kids in mass all of those things
i'm actually not sure
i i don't know i suspect in some weird
way yes because i think absolute power
corrupts absolutely so i do think
there's some perverse thing that you see
with a lot of these progressives where
it's like the more they can tell you to
wear masks and that's why they flaunt
the rules and then they go out or they
go to parties or whatever it might be or
they send their kids to school without
mess the more they can do it and throw
it in your face it shows them that
they're sort of powerful they're the
ones in charge i actually in this case
will try
not to guess fauci's motivation
i don't know if he's enjoying this i
don't know if he thinks i suppose a year
and a half after two weeks to finally
heard that he's an abject failure i
suppose at some level he must if he's
been the guy leading this and we're in
such a bad place as we're being told
right now and all these people are so
anti-vaccine despite all of his
messaging he must sort of in his
personal life i suppose at some level
feel that he's a failure but anyway he
keeps going on these tv shows he smiles
he laughs he gets these softball
interviews and here he is over the
weekend talking about whether we can get
together
for christmas
we can gather for christmas or it's just
too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got a concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time let's focus like a
laser on continuing to get those those
cases down and we can do it by people
getting vaccinated and also in the
situation where boosters are appropriate
let's get those numbers down he's got
that same uh
same affect as bernie um notice he
doesn't say the numbers right like we
know this already i read if you watch my
interview
my debate with gloria allred 0.002
of children under 18 are dying because
of covid basically if you're under 80
and you're not
overweight or diabetic you survive covet
but they're not giving us any numbers
they'll on any given day it went up 50
it went down 20 percent it went up a
hundred percent but you know if you have
two people and it goes to four people
that's very you know it's like you guys
all get this and so some of this is not
worth repeating but just this idea that
at this point i i just can't imagine
let's just say fauci is as good of a man
as he possibly could be well if he's
trying as hard as he can and he's
failing at this level a year and a half
later then he has to step aside but the
idea that he would dare
say to anyone now
at the beginning of october in 2021
after this all started basically in
february of 2020 that maybe or we'll
have to debate whether we're going to
get together with our families for
christmas
i'm jewish i'll be together with my
family for christmas i promise you
actually we all love christmas it's that
you know it's we can watch the the fire
on tv and it's pretty spectacular right
that the point is it's like enough stop
listening to these people no well you
make a choice for yourself i can't
listen to these people i just can't i
just don't know what they're saying as
you guys know two weeks ago i was in new
york uh really for the first extended
trip since this whole thing began and it
was the first time in a year and a half
that my parents my brother's family my
sister's family and david and i had all
got together it was the first time in a
year and a half that's what they stole
from a lot of people i know even now
there are people who haven't seen their
parents or haven't had big family
get-togethers or everything or anything
else that's what they stole from us
they're stealing our life in real time
and we're letting them do it uh but
there's more we've got uh fauci then
following up
uh talking about right which is sort of
interesting let's listen to fouchy on
right
but you are a member of society
and as a member of society
reaping all the benefits of being a
member of society you have a
responsibility
to society
and i think each of us particularly in
the context
of a pandemic that's killing
millions of people
you have got to look at it and say there
comes a time
when you do have to give up
what you consider your individual right
of making your own decision
for the greater good of society
god that is so dangerous you have to
give up your individual right for the
greater good i get it if you listen to
it at this level it sort of sounds right
but just
think for a second once you give up your
individual rights do you think they will
give them back to you do you guys see
what's going on in australia right now
they don't want to give you your
individual rights back to you and it's
not just your individual rights it's
what you inject yourself with it's
whether you go to work who you're around
whether you can be with your parent as
as they're dying
if you're vaccinated or not this is
extraordinary he also says millions of
people uh there's less than seven
hundred thousand dead in the us uh
because of covet and my guess is that
that's somewhat over reported because
they probably died of some other things
and the comorbidities and everything
else i get worldwide perhaps millions of
people but in the united states it's
less than 700 000 people can we get the
numbers on how many like roughly over
we're over 80 let's say let's get a
number on that um but this meme now that
you have to give up something to them
who clearly got everything wrong this
entire time which is why we're in this
situation right now and the vaccines
that aren't working as promised and get
your next booster shot and we know oh it
does it's actually not a vaccine and
that it's going to keep you safe you'll
somehow get less sick like this
never-ending thing but we'll just take a
little more of your rights
we'll just take can we just have a few
more of those rights from you and then
we'll see when you get them back because
you better that's for the greater good
like have you guys ever read any basic
psychology or or basically any sort of
dystopian novel ever it's all it's all
that so okay this is this is
extraordinary so 80
of the it's about
693 000 people who have died in the
united states over covid
80 of them according to the cdc i am
giving you stats right now that we are
pulling up in real time according to the
cdc 80 of those people are over 65. that
is not to diminish any of those people's
lives
i love
older people i want my parents to be
safe i want everyone to do whatever they
have to do for themselves but when we're
making it sound like as he's saying
millions and millions of people are
dying all over this 80 percent of people
over 65 a good percentage of them were
going to die of other things anyway and
sometimes there's a really bad flu that
that gets a lot of people so it's
dangerous stuff the way they play with
numbers but this meme of give up your
rights or you don't have rights is
fascinating and we're watching it
proliferate throughout the system right
now
which is one of the things i talk about
you often get like these
politicians or in this case someone like
fouchy these government bureaucrats to
say something and then the idea sort of
gets laundered throughout the media so
in my interview with legendary this
woman's considered a legendary civil
rights lawyer one of the biggest civil
rights lawyers we've had in america for
probably the past four decades in my
debate with gloria allred which again
you can see the full thing is up on
youtube right now i put up this morning
she also said we should give up our
rights take a look this is really not
about rights it's about
life and death but you just said
something very very dangerous right
there for a lawyer this is not about
rights
since when is it not about rights in the
united states we have god-given rights
that are protected under the
constitution and the bill of rights
i mean
i say something you decide right like
it's not about right it's fouchy it's
not about rights civil rights lawyer
it's not about rights what is about
rights then when do you get to make some
decisions for yourself and do what's
right for you
i think i mentioned this on thursday or
friday i'm getting messages my inbox is
absolutely blown up with people who are
being laid off from hospitals and from
airlines and from all sorts of places of
employment right now some people who
don't even work in offices nor ever have
worked in offices because they won't get
jabbed i got an email from a guy who's a
hospital administrator who has been
working at home in his basement for
years before kovid he has now been laid
off
give up a few more of your rights guys
why not you know give them access to
your bank accounts and your phone
records and all that stuff it's for your
own good they're looking for somebody a
bad person you know so just give up some
of your rights and and don't worry they
don't want you to talk about certain
things don't talk about certain things
give up some of your rights and then you
know you'll be a good citizen anyway
please do watch my full interview or my
full debate rather with gloria allred i
think it's actually probably the best
sort of most succinct debate i've ever
had with anyone i'm very proud of it
because she just spouts endless nonsense
and and when was the last time you got
laid line was pretty good so yeah
all right let's talk about uh
representative
ayanna presley she is one of the squad
alongside such luminaries as aoc ilhan
omar and rashida talib and what these
people consistently do is they say
buzzwords endless endless buzzwords that
actually mean nothing but a certain
segment of society thinks that because
they've said x amount of nonsensical
buzzwords often things that none of us
said year you know four or five years
ago that that somehow gives them cachet
and value and it means that they're
making sense and then the media then
pushes these things because these are
the good guys and they're standing up
for all of these groups that they just
made up and everything else
and well here's exhibit a 2021 has been
the most devastating for abortion rights
in american history in the midst of an
ongoing global pandemic that robbed us
of more than 690
lives and disproportionately impacted
our most vulnerable and black and brown
communities anti-abortion legislators in
47 states focused on legislating hurt
and harm to push this critical health
care out of reach
these misguided bans will not actually
prevent all abortions they simply put
safe and necessary abortion care out of
reach for our most vulnerable
specifically our lowest income sisters
our queer trans and non-binary siblings
black latinx aapi immigrants disabled
and indigenous indigenous folks
and none of this is happenstance it is
precise like the roots of the
anti-abortion movement these bans are
rooted in patriarchy and white supremacy
god these people are just ridiculous
like where do i start first off if we
were just playing like meaningless
buzzword bingo it's like lady
congratulations you're getting a box of
donuts like jesus christ i i would love
to know how she thinks that queer and
gay people are going to be struggling
because of the uh these pro-life laws
that she says are being pushed by the
way no one has banned abortion no one
has banned abortion period it's against
the law because of roe v wade roe v wade
is a federal law saying that the states
cannot make their own decisions related
to abortion that the right to an
abortion is a federal law now we can
argue whether that's a sane
decision or not or whether it should be
kicked back to the states but even in
texas which did pass this six-week law
it's not a ban on abortion you still
have six weeks to get abortion and again
you guys know my feelings on this like i
don't even agree with the six weeks
thing but these people they just say
crazy things that first of all they keep
calling it health care and it's like
well it's not really health care like
you are killing a baby right like
depends on your definition i guess it's
loosely it's health care um but you know
and then of course she links it to the
patriarchy and white supremacy and the
rest of this nonsense it's affecting
black and latinx like find me a latino
who says latinx or lepinx please that
would be a pleasure aapi what's that
asian and pacific island or something
like that immigrants and disabled and
indigenous folks you see how they just
say these crazy things like is there
some massive problem we're having with
disabled people who want to have
abortions is that really think how
stupid that statement is like is there
really a problem indigenous folks are
having huge abortion like it's all
nonsense everything they say is nonsense
and but a certain amount of people hear
that and they go my god our low income
sisters and our queer and trans latinx
aapi brothers and sisters they're
hurting man we got to do something by
the way the democrats
voted just in the last couple days i
think we talked about it briefly last
week
to pass a bill
it passed 218 to 11 so i guess it didn't
actually pass right like that was just
how they voted on it
we'll get a little more info on this but
the democrats it's not a law yet but the
democrats voted 218 to one
that a woman could have an abortion at
any stage in her pregnancy as long as
she had one health care professional
that said it was okay and that could
include mental health so you could be at
eight months and be freaking out for
good reason you know it's a lot of
stress to have a kid and you could be
like all right i'm gonna have an
abortion like that's how extreme these
people have become and it's like in a
sane society we would have an honest
debate about this stuff and we can as
you know talk about when the sperm meets
the egg talk about a few weeks where
it's mostly just a clump of cells talk
about when the heartbeat starts and all
of those things and i'm pretty well
versed in this as we're going through
surrogacy and believe it or not a couple
days in after the sperm meets the egg
you can know the sex the same people who
will tell you to believe in science and
that you know gender doesn't even exist
and it's like we know right now we have
a certain amount of male
embryos and we have a certain amount of
female embryos we don't have a certain
amount of oh pick your
gender embryos like that's not a thing
i'm fairly certain that my
our guy is a you know scientist he's a
man of science like he knows what he's
doing he's a fertility doctor he's not
like oh you know you got a ten embryos
here we got uh you know three male
three female and four you know they'll
decide like that's not a thing it's not
a thing anyway these people
they're just bananas okay this was the
really big story over the weekend and
this gets to the heart of
almost everything that is wrong with
society right now and that's why we had
to cover it um so christian cinema is a
democratic senator from arizona i would
say she's one of the last sort of
remotely moderate democrats there aren't
many yes i know your uncle is one and
there's a couple that you're friends
with every now and again but in terms of
influential
moderate old-school liberal democrats i
would say bill maher for whatever my
frustrations are with lamar he's one
there's there's a few of these people
left cinema actually in many ways is a
progressive but all she's doing in this
case
is saying that she will not vote for
this 3.5 trillion dollar spending bill
okay and joe manchin is doing the exact
same thing uh she's saying it's just too
much spending and she also is tacitly
acknowledging that they're lying because
they keep telling you 3.5 trillion
dollars will cost nothing now the way
they're rationalizing that
is that they're saying it won't add
anything to the deficit because we're
just going to take money from other
people it's a it's an extraordinary lie
anyone with basic math would understand
not even math i mean you just have to
take one logic class to understand that
if you spend 3.5 trillion dollars it's
not zero even if you just steal it from
other people that's still spending money
okay it's just not adding to your to
your own personal debt and i have no
doubt that it would add to the debt
anyway because we're a debtor nation and
we got to pay interest and china may
come collecting some of that stuff one
day so we're probably gonna have to bomb
them but that's a whole other story
anyway kristen cinema is taking what i
believe is a principal position saying
this bill is just way too much in
spending by the way joe manchin who i
said is the other democrat that is not
going for this thing he posted publicly
a letter that he had sent to chuck
schumer i think about two months ago
where he said basically chuck i'm not
going to sign on to anything more than
1.5 trillion now this thing's 3.5
trillion and i get it they just make up
the numbers it's all nonsensical
but it's not as if manchin is suddenly
doing something that people didn't
expect him to do and cinema was thought
of as not sort of like the perfect crazy
leftist that was always going to go on
the party line anyway she uh was chased
into a bathroom i believe this is at the
arizona capitol am i right uh the
university sorry at the university of
arizona state she was chased into a
bathroom by several activists uh we'll
tell you more about the activists in
just a sec
okay i'll be back
we want to talk to you real quick
actually i am heading out
but um right now is a real moment that
our people need in order for us to be
able to talk about what's really
happening
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we we're not going forward we need
solutions and to build that better
we knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us we
need 7 million citizenship for 7 million
we need the belgrave right now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old
and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sp 1070
and i'm here because i definitely
believe that we need this pathway to
citizenship my grandfather passed away
two weeks ago and i was not able to go
to mexico and visit him because there is
no pathway to citizenship and if we have
the opportunity to pass it right now
then we need to do it because there's
millions of undocumented people just
like me who share the same story or even
worse things that happen to them because
of sb 1070 and because of anti-immigrant
legislation and this is opportunity to
pass it right now and we need you to we
need to hold you accountable to what you
told us what you promised us that you
were going to pass when we knocked on
doors for you it's not
i'm right survivor
i'm a survivor of human trafficking and
it's because of the lack of worker
protections that we don't have in the
gay economy i need you to stand by
workers
okay so let's just be clear about
something here the girl who's doing most
of the talking there that they you know
once they followed cinema into the
bathroom she's an undocumented immigrant
that's what she says herself she's an
illegal immigrant so she is here
illegally she is basically stalking
a sitting member of the senate in the
bathroom demanding that she
does what she wants to do we helped you
get in and now you got to do what we
want you to do i mean
i don't want to make this about that
girl but it's like
why is she here now right like if you're
undocumented and we know you're
undocumented i'm not i'm really not like
some crazy immigration hawk either i i
believe especially for young people that
were brought here if they're you know
functioning productive members of
society that aren't involved in crime
and everything else we should have that
pathway to citizenship and again it's
one of those things much like i often
talk about with abortion where if we
were in a sane society we could talk
about the marginal cases we could talk
about the common ground but basically
you have an undocumented immigrant
busting into a bathroom with a couple
other people uh to in essence they're
threatening her like why else are you
getting in her face now we all know that
maxine waters said you should get in
their faces she was talking about
conservatives in this case i don't know
if she fully thought it would come to
roost in her own party with her own uh
you know democratic senators um but this
is what they want in in essence i was
talking there she said i was brought
here to the united states when i was
three years old in 2010 both my
grandparents got deported because of sb
1070. so her grandparents obviously came
here illegally they got deported we
could debate whether that was right or
not or what their individual situation
is but now she's undocumented but she
has the gall
as an undocumented citizen as someone
that is here illegally
to chase a senator down into the
bathroom now we know we know that this
isn't going to get major play obviously
on cnn or on msnbc or on washington post
or new york times because this doesn't
fit the narrative right this is well in
a certain respect it does fit the
narrative in that it's oh this senator
is not extreme enough so the base is
angry but then it would have if they did
cover it truly and honestly they would
have to uncover the real issues here of
why are undocumented people harassing
senators but let's be very clear about
something which is that if these were a
bunch of trump supporters or
conservatives or
anti-abortion activists or anything else
remotely thought of as crazy right which
is everything except looney left uh we
know that they these people would be
arrested that we would be arresting
family members they would be breaking
into houses and looking for documents
and everything else but this is what
they have wrought now even more
fascinating than all of this is that joe
biden was asked about this incident this
morning asked about whether you know you
can just follow senators into the
bathroom and start yelling at them
here's what joe said mr president mr
president uh you're talking about how
you have
48 democratic votes right now the other
two
have been pressured over the weekend by
activists joe manchin had people on
kayaks show up to his boat t.l adam
senator cinema last night was chased
into a restroom do you think that those
tactics are crossing a line
i don't think they're appropriate
tactics but it happens to everybody
from
the only people it doesn't happen to are
people who have secret service stand
around them um so it's it's part of the
process yes
it's part of the process that's the part
where he said the honest thing it's part
of the process meaning yeah if you
harass people that don't agree with me
it's part of the process yeah yeah we've
got secret service so you usually can't
get to us
but you know it's part of the process
just imagine if donald trump had said
that imagine if anti-abortion activists
busted into a bathroom started harassing
aoc and then trump was asked about it he
said that's part of the process
we would be in an impeachment now
right this moment same day impeachment
three
the trilogy it would be here these
people are just liars they lie about
absolutely everything and they will
gladly use intimidation and political
violence when they can but
to end on a positive note the people the
people who i stand with the good
freedom-loving people of the united
states have had
had have just had enough of it they've
just had enough of it and at many many
public gatherings usually at sports
arenas and at stadiums and things there
has been a really interesting chant
going around that you may have heard
this is from nbc news after
i believe was a nascar race yesterday
thank you to all of our partners
oh my god it's just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
as you can hear the chance from the the
crowd
[Music]
let's go brandon brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two stages and just watch and learn what
did you learn that helped you there in
those closing laps oh my god it was uh
learning how each line didn't uh
stay to one and everything shifted top
to bottom all right look i wish
political discourse was a little bit
better than it is i usually try to do my
best to to you know give some space for
that to happen sometimes i don't do it
perfectly
but there's a really incredible thing
that just happened there it's not just
that the audience is chanting [ __ ] joe
biden and it's happening in stadiums
across the united states like people are
just fed up they're fed up of being told
what they have to inject in their body
they're fed up with being told when they
can see their family and whether they
can celebrate christmas and everything
else and everyone knows something's
wrong with joe biden and it's like we're
not allowed to talk about that and you
can't talk about elections and blah blah
blah people just had it so they're
chanting [ __ ] joe biden the nbc reporter
there did you catch what she did
she said that they were chanting let's
go brandon
not [ __ ] joe biden can we play that
again brandon
thank you to all of our partners
oh my god it's just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me as you can hear
the chance from the the crowd
[Music]
let's go brandon brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two stages and just watch
that's some fine work there nbc guys uh
my full debate with civil rights
legendary that's what they always say
legendary civil rights attorney who
doesn't care about rights anymore gloria
allred is up on our youtube channel
right now my full interview with jack
posobiac is up right now as well and
part one of my interview with blake
masters who is running for senate in
arizona okay so he could be having the
seat next to christian cinema he's
running against mark kelly uh he is a
really if you don't know him he's sort
of just coming on the scene right now we
did the interview live in studio here
he's just sort of coming on the scene he
uh he wrote zero to one with peter thiel
he's he's a young
sort of what i would say is a new school
conservative like like got the right
ideas related to tech and and how we
should think about government and care
about families and individual rights and
all of the nonsense that we're being
that's being pushed on us he's he's kind
of pushing back on it and i think he's
got a real chance so part one of my
interview with blake masters is up on
youtube right now the full thing
is up on uh local so you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com
and i only have one other thing to say
today which is
let's go brandon
see you tomorrow